What can spiders teach us?
Aside from abject fear.
Hi spider men and women, Julian here for DNews.
There’s a widely circulated factoid that
claims spider silk is 5 times stronger than
steel, which is true, in a way.
There are a lot of different spider silks
and a lot of different grades of steels.
Some of the strongest silk can withstand over
1 GPa of tugging before it snaps.
By comparison a steel wire the same thickness
can have a tensile strength almost twice as
high, but when you consider that spider silk
is much lighter than steel, then, yes, it
can have about 5 times the tensile strength
of steel by density.
Not as pithy as the factoid, but more accurate.
The area where spider silk really beats steel
is toughness.
Spider silk is extremely ductile, meaning
it can really stretch out.
That, combined with the amount of force needed
to break it when it won’t stretch anymore
means it can absorb 3x as much energy as kevlar
before breaking, which explains why Cap couldn’t
get his hands free.
Obviously if we could replicate spider silk
synthetically it could have a lot of applications,
but we’re still untangling its secrets.
(See what I did there?)
There have been a few mechanisms that scientists
believe contribute to the silk’s ductility.
In 2012 Dr Markus Buehler of MIT reported
to the journal Nature that he had found four
stages the silk underwent as it stretched.
First the thread is pulled tight, then the
proteins themselves start to unfold, the thread
then stiffens, and finally when it starts
breaking, it does so a little bit at a time.
When the hydrogen bonds holding the proteins
together break, some of them immediately reform.
It does this repeatedly, with fewer bonds
coming back together each time, until they
can’t reform anymore and the thread snaps.
The protein stretching and hydrogen bond failsafes
are hard to replicate in a cost effective
way.
Multiple attempts have failed, including one
that used genetically modified goats that
made a protein in their milk that could be
spun into spider silk.
But scientists have recently made a discovery
about spider silk that makes it’s stretchiness
more replicable with the materials we already
have.
Scientists at the University of Oxford and
the Université Pierre et Marie Curie noticed
that the orb spider’s silk is always taught.
Bend it, shape it anyway you want it, as long
as you tug it, it’s alright.
Not only that, but when it’s compressed
it still stays taught.
On closer examination they found thousands
of watery glue droplets along the strand,
each a tenth of a millimeter across.
The glue is useful for trapping prey, but
on top of that it helps give the thread its
elasticity.
When the the filament shortened, these droplets
would reel in the slack.
When pulled on, they would spool it out again.
The silk could be elongated and shortened
as many times as the researchers liked and
it would still behave just the same.
With that model in mind, the scientists placed
a droplet of oil on a plastic filament and
viola, they made themselves a “liquid wire.”
It stretched out like a solid, but contracted
like a liquid, making it a hybrid material.
Though the droplet was much bigger than the
spider’s glue and the plastic was much simpler,
they still managed to mimic some spider silk
properties, and they didn’t have to use
a single spider goat to do it.
The researchers are optimistic their discovery
can be used when microfabricating complex
structures, reversible micromotors, or other
tiny systems that need to be able to stretch
and retract themselves.
If you want more DNews, you're not alone.
So, with that in mind we launched a brand
new website: Seeker.com.
There, you can find all of DNews’ over 2400
episodes, plus original articles, photos,
and more great videos about science, the world,
politics, and even adventure and exploration.
Click the link in the description to check
it out, and if you like it, help us spread
the word!
It's brand new!
Thanks.
If you love science as much as we all do here
at DNews, make sure to check out the new shows
on DirecTV Mobile to get even more science.
Click the link in the description
below to subscribe!”
Spider webs are fascinating.
Spider sex is terrifying.
To learn why and get a song stuck in your
head all day, check out Trace’s video here.
Is learning how to mimic a spider web’s
ability to stretch worth the utter horror
you experience every time you walk through
one in the dark?